Trascrizione: Virginia Bechini
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Di cosa parliamo, quando parliamo
di rappresentazione audiovisiva?
Innanzitutto, occorre
sottolineare un aspetto:
la rappresentazione televisiva
e audiovisiva, innanzitutto,
è quella del cinema oppure della tv.
La rappresentazione audiovisiva
non è la realtà;
è quello che si sceglie
di mostrare della realtà,
e come si sceglie di mostrarlo.
Adesso vorrei chiedervi di immaginare
una grande stanza buia,
con un singolo angolo illuminato.
Davanti a quel singolo angolo illuminato,
c'è una telecamera.
E davanti all'obiettivo
di quella telecamera,
c'è qualcosa di simile
al set di una rivista di design.
Tutto è di gran gusto, tutto è perfetto.
E cosa c'è nel buio intorno?
Il disordine,
quello che non si vuole fare vedere.
Questa immagine per raccontarvi
che la rappresentazione audiovisiva,
quale per esempio quella delle serie tv
di cui un po' parleremo oggi,
esiste per rispondere
a un bisogno della società;
e questo bisogno della società
è fare bella figura.
Di conseguenza,
quello che arriverà davanti all'obiettivo,
nell'angolo illuminato,
saranno storie che non pongono
un problema alla società,
di nessun tipo.
Quindi vedremo tanti - come ne vediamo -
amori eterosessuali, storie di famiglia;
vedremo tanti corpi conformi;
vedremo tanti corpi bianchi,
vedremo tante persone bianche.
Mentre al contrario, nell'oscurità
rimarranno le storie,
le persone e le categorie sociali
che sfidano la società,
che pongono un problema alla società
perché la società
non è in grado di gestire
l'oppressione sistemica
che tocca a queste persone,
a queste categorie, a queste storie.
La rappresentazione audiovisiva è potere.
Ed è un potere duplice,
è un potere che è come una medaglia:
ci sono due facce di quella medaglia,
e sono un po' in quella storia
della stanza buia
con un singolo angolo illuminato.
La rappresentazione audiovisiva
ha il potere di fare vedere delle cose;
ma simultaneamente
di inabissarne delle altre,
quindi di lasciare nel buio delle altre.
C'è un'espressione molto bella,
e che io uso spesso,
che è stata coniata da un mass mediologo
degli anni '70, di nome George Gerbner.
George Gerbner ha parlato delle persone,
delle categorie sociali,
e delle storie non rappresentate
come se fossero annientate simbolicamente.
Questo è il grande potere
della rappresentazione audiovisiva:
la visibilità versus l'invisibilizzazione.
Quello che si vede esiste,
quello che non si vede non esiste.
Adesso cominciamo un po'
a parlare di serie tv.
Sono sicura che qua, in questa platea,
ci sono almeno una buona parte di persone
che guardano abitualmente serie tv.
Le serie tv sono meravigliose,
sono il mio mestiere;
e fanno parte della nostra routine,
fanno parte della nostra vita.
Le portiamo con noi,
spesso riempiono i nostri momenti vuoti,
spesso le nostre serate.
Sono davvero sulla bocca
di tutte le persone;
e per dirvi fino a che punto
sono sulla bocca delle persone,
mi basta darvi dei numeri.
Sono certa che conoscete
una certa compagnia di nome Netflix.
Netflix nel 2001 -
cosa che non tutte le persone
effettivamente sanno -
era molto diversa da quello che è oggi,
perché era un servizio di noleggio dvd,
e contava 400.000 persone abbonate.
Mutatis mutandis, andiamo avanti a oggi,
20 anni dopo, nel 2021.
Netflix conta 203,66 milioni
di persone abbonate,
in 190 paesi;
e noi non la conosciamo più
come servizio di noleggio dvd,
ma la conosciamo come celeberrima
struttura produttiva.
Ho detto Netflix, ma potevo anche fare
un altro esempio, credetemi:
quindi potevo, per esempio,
parlare di Disney Plus,
che è arrivata in Italia l'anno scorso,
è disponibile in 59 paesi
e ha 100 milioni di persone abbonate.
Quindi ecco, sono davvero grandi numeri;
ci intratteniamo molto
con la serialità televisiva, con i film,
con la rappresentazione audiovisiva.
Anche se non lo sappiamo,
noi passiamo tantissimo tempo
a guardare l'angolo
illuminato della stanza.
Adesso, infatti, vorrei parlarvi
di una serie tv che io amo molto,
e che vi consiglio di scoprire peraltro,
se già non la conoscete;
la trovate su Netflix, si chiama Special.
È una serie speciale di nome e di fatto,
perché è un po' un unicorno;
è stata infatti non solo interpretata,
ma anche scritta,
da questo ragazzo che vedete,
che si chiama Ryan O'Connell.
Ryan O' Conner è un ragazzo gay,
con paralisi celebrale;
dunque è un ragazzo con disabilità
che è riuscito a penetrare nei ranghi
di un sistema molto complesso,
raccontando una storia
che lo vede protagonista.
Purtroppo, Special è stata cancellata
dopo sole due stagioni,
di cui una da episodi da 12 minuti l'una,
non è un grande impegno.
E perché io vi voglio
proprio parlare di Special?
Al di là del fatto che,
come vi dicevo, è un unicorno,
qualche tempo fa ho intervistato
questo signore qua,
e anche qui sono ragionevolmente certa
che qualche persona, qui,
ha idea di chi sia.
Si tratta di Jim Parsons,
meglio noto come lo Sheldon Cooper
di The Big Bang Theory.
Ma in maniera, in realtà,
abbastanza distante dal suo personaggio
di The Big Bang Theory,
Jim Parsons è un attivista
per i diritti della comunità LGBTQIA+.
È uno dei produttori di Special,
quindi fu una bella coincidenza per me.
Ha prodotto Special assieme a suo marito,
che si chiama Tod Spiewak,
e io gli domandai di Special.
Gli chiesi: "Com'è andata?"
"Come avete fatto a produrla?",
perché appunto è una serie
abbastanza differente dalle altre.
E lui mi rispose:
"È stato veramente complicato!
Ci abbiamo messo oltre tre anni,
perché Hollywood ha molti guardiani."
Questa frase a me è rimasta
molto, molto impressa.
E ora che vi ho parlato di Special,
e vi ho parlato della difficoltà
di Jim Parsons a produrre Special,
vorrei farvi vedere un semplice grafico
che ho estrapolato dal report del GLAAD.
Il GLAAD è un ente statistico
che si occupa di monitorare
la rappresentazione audiovisiva,
soprattutto della comunità LGBTQIA+;
però anche di marginalizzazione,
della rappresentazione anche
di altre marginalizzazioni,
tra cui, appunto, quella della disabilità.
Ora, detto che secondo
il Center for Disease Control
negli Stati Uniti vivono
61 milioni di persone con disabilità,
il GLAAD ha trovato nelle sue analisi
che su oltre 500 serie tv
in onda negli Stati Uniti in un solo anno,
su tutte le piattaforme,
su tutti i canali commerciali,
la rappresentazione
delle persone con disabilità
si aggira intorno al 3,5%.
Cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che le persone con disabilità,
secondo il nostro ragionamento,
sono annientate simbolicamente.
Vuol dire che la rappresentazione
non copre le loro storie.
E che queste persone non riescono
a entrare nelle strutture produttive
per fare arrivare a noi le loro storie.
Qui vorrei aprire e chiudere
molto velocemente una parentesi.
Questa è stata la prima volta di due
in cui utilizzo dei dati
relativi agli Stati Uniti.
Voi direte: ma noi siamo in Italia,
ma perché, Marina, non usi
delle statistiche italiane invece?
Perché le statistiche italiane,
in relazione alla
rappresentazione audiovisiva,
ma soprattutto in relazione
alle strutture del potere audiovisivo -
quindi case di produzione etc -
queste mappature probabilmente esistono,
ma non sono facilmente accessibili.
C'è sicuramente il Diversity Lab,
che si occupa di
rappresentazione qualitativa;
ma qui parliamo proprio di capire
chi si siede in un certo tipo
di posizioni da noi.
Io ho provato a fare
un po' questo esperimento,
con la TED speaker Donata Columbro
di "Data Ninja School".
Però è davvero un'impresa onerosa;
mi auguro tanto che si riesca a farla.
Chiusa parentesi.
Torniamo ai nostri Stati Uniti,
dove abbiamo i grafici;
e vorrei invitarvi a guardare l'apice
della piramide di questo grafico,
parlando di strutture
del potere audiovisivo.
Come vedete c'è un dato
che colpisce, almeno a me colpisce;
nella posizione di CEO,
dunque nella massima posizione decisionale
in relazione alla
rappresentazione audiovisiva,
si trovano il 92% di persone bianche;
e il 68% di queste persone sono uomini.
Il che vuol dire che, di fatto,
la rappresentazione audiovisiva,
questo grande potere,
è nelle mani di una singola
categoria sociale: gli uomini bianchi.
Io sono sicura
che tra questo 68% di uomini bianchi
ci sono delle persone straordinarie:
il punto non è questo.
Il punto è l'unica storia;
il punto è che sulle sedie del potere
si siedono pochissime donne.
E a proposito di donne,
di sedie del potere e di storie,
come vi è stato anticipato,
io mi occupo molto
di "viaggio dell'eroina".
Il viaggio dell'eroina è una variante
rispetto al viaggio dell'eroe;
ma è una ingombrante variante!
Solo che è pochissimo studiata,
perché si parla sempre,
invece, di viaggio eroico
come di viaggio eroico maschile.
E si sostiene che in realtà
sia la stessa cosa.
Che il viaggio dell'eroe,
la struttura in tre atti
con cui vengono costruite
la stragrande maggior parte
delle storie che noi fruiamo,
si sostiene che sia unisex
quando in realtà non lo è.
Vi voglio dire che il viaggio dell'eroe
discende in particolare da un libro,
che è "L'eroe dai mille volti"
del professor Joseph Campbell;
mentre il viaggio dell'eroina
discende più o meno, invece,
da Maureen Murdock,
un'autrice che seguiva
i seminari di Joseph Campbell.
Allora un giorno Maureen Murdock
andò da Joseph Campbell e gli chiese:
"Professore, è tutto meraviglioso,
terribilmente affascinante;
ma mi può per favore spiegare perché,
siccome voi parlate sempre di eroe -
cosa succede alla donna se è la donna,
la protagonista di una storia?"
E il nostro amico Joseph Campbell
rispose alla nostra amica Maureen Murdock:
"La donna non è viaggiatrice,
la donna è meta".
Questo è il potere delle storie;
e il potere delle storie tracima
nella rappresentazione audiovisiva.
Quindi per tanto tempo, e ancora oggi,
le donne sono considerate
mete, non viaggiatrici.
E tra l'altro, cosa che mi fa
ancora più specie,
è che si parla sempre de "Le Donne".
Come se fossimo -
Avete presente le caramelle
che si prendono
con la paletta nel negozio?
tutte della stessa forma,
tutte con lo stesso sapore,
tutte magari con lo zucchero sopra?
Ma noi siamo tutte diverse!
Noi abbiamo tutte esperienze diverse!
Noi abbiamo corpi conformi,
corpi non conformi,
siamo grasse,
siamo di seconda generazione,
siamo lesbiche, pansessuali, bisessuali,
vogliamo dei figli, non li vogliamo.
Non ci sono due donne
che abbiano la stessa storia.
Infatti il problema, qui,
non è soltanto cosa si trova
davanti all'obiettivo della telecamera,
nel singolo angolo
illuminato della stanza;
il problema è, anche,
chi sta dietro la telecamera.
Chi è che racconta quelle storie?
Sono sempre le stesse persone?
È possibile.
Chimamanda Ngozi Adichie,
favolosa TED speaker,
nel suo TED Talk
"Il pericolo di un'unica storia"
ha detto: "Il potere è la possibilità
non solo di raccontare
la storia di un'altra persona,
ma di farla diventare
la storia definitiva di quella persona."
Cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che, certo, quando parliamo
di storytelling vale tutto;
però se si parla di identità,
e se si parla di esperienza socioculturale
del proprio corpo nella realtà,
allora se io che sono una donna cis,
cioè io sono una donna
che si identifica con il sesso
che le è stato assegnato alla nascita,
se io scrivo la storia di una donna trans,
e quindi la storia di quella donna trans
finisce nell'angolo
illuminato della stanza,
io non ho idea di che cosa voglia dire
fare l'esperienza di quel corpo,
avere quelle sensazioni,
vivere quella vita.
Perché il punto è anche questo.
Ripeto, con lo storytelling
vale tutto, non c'è dubbio;
non siamo ancorati alla realtà,
non abbiamo i pesi ai piedi
per cui dobbiamo solo parlare di realtà;
ma la nostra esperienza personale
e l'esperienza che noi facciamo
con le nostre identità
informa anche la fantasia,
in maniere imprevedibili e meravigliose;
è la base della pluralità che si auspica
per l'industria audiovisiva
e per la serialità televisiva.
Ed è per questo che io dico:
dobbiamo restituire le storie
alle persone rappresentate.
Ma come fare?
Come fare.
Non ci sono poche storie,
per esempio, di donne nere;
ma tantissime sono scritte
da persone bianche.
Non ci sono poche storie di donne,
ma tantissime nella stragrande -
e non c'è niente che non va -
ma nella maggioranza
sono scritte da uomini.
Come si fa a sfondare quel muro,
come si fa a oltrepassare quel confine?
Io credo che sia necessario
qualcosa di più
dell'affidarsi semplicemente al buon cuore
o alle opportunità che cascano in grembo
di volta in volta,
di quella struttura o di un'altra.
Io credo che siano necessari
degli aiuti solidi,
anche da parte della politica,
da parte degli Stati,
per far sì che persone
con esperienze differenti
si avvicinino all'industria audiovisiva.
E quando si parla
di industria audiovisiva,
di cosa si parla?
Si parla di scuole di recitazione,
si parla di scuole di regia,
di direzione, della fotografia,
Si parla di scuole di sceneggiatura:
in tutto questo, le persone
che non sono rappresentate,
le persone che sono
annientate simbolicamente
finiscono inevitabilmente
per autosqualificarsi,
perché percepiscono
che non c'è posto per loro, lì.
E che cosa succede dunque?
Che noi continuiamo
a vedere un'unica storia.
Ora va meglio che in passato, per carità;
ma la strada è davvero, davvero lunga.
E io sono convinta
che non sia più tempo di aggirare
i guardiani di Jim Parsons di soppiatto;
credo che sia arrivato il momento
di espugnare la fortezza con un grido.
(Applausi)